let's go next to
how about
stevie from asheville north carolina
stevie welcome
hey david uh thanks for having me on my
pleasure um
i just had a question a little bit of a
specific question today or a second
theme is supreme court but um so in the
idea of or in counseling there's this
concept of duty to protect whereas a
client has confidentiality from their
therapist in most cases except for a few
specific ones and just like to list one
for instance uh child abuse if a client
were to disclose to a therapist that
they're abusing their child then duty to
warn dirty to protect the councilor
would have to inform the law of course
my question is in the wake of some of
this in the wake of the supreme court
decision in which some states are going
to ban abortion i'm curious if some
states are going to say oh a fetus that
is a child if a if a
client were to say they're seeking an
abortion outside of the state does would
that fall under child abuse and would
the counselor have a duty to protect for
um an unborn child
so they would absolutely argue that i
think the question would be
whether local police could really do
anything about it because let's imagine
a different example i guess
imagine that a client disclosed to a
client in texas disclosed to their
therapist i'm planning to kill someone
in amsterdam or something like that okay
so the therapist can go and they can
call texas police and texas police maybe
could ask some questions but they really
probably can't do anything the the crime
is supposedly going to happen in
amsterdam and then if you call amsterdam
police and say this person might be
doing this thing they would say okay
thanks for letting us know if they come
to amsterdam
then we will be aware of it but there's
nothing they can do until the person is
there so in the in thinking about the
instance of a oh abortion's banned in
texas you tell your therapist i'm gonna
go to neighboring wherever to get uh an
abortion i don't think texas police can
really do anything about it because it's
not a crime in that other state and
they're not planning to do it in texas
yeah i think that they will make the
argument but i don't think it will be
very effective at doing anything
right i think that it all comes back to
trying to enforce abortion laws like
this in general is just kind of silly
yes it is it absolutely is and uh there
are going to be all sorts of absurd
situations like this for sure but but
we'll have to deal with them as they
come up
right okay well that that's just the uh
thought i've been having lately uh thank
you for having me on all right stevie
from asheville very much appreciate it
nice connection got right to the
question
hard to beat that